[Music]
Mrs buttkiss had a big problem she had a
terrible case of gas forever and she was
afraid to let it out because she had no
idea what would
happen Mrs buus was a very large woman
she also had a humongous
butt so she worried that there would be
a huge
explosion if she ever farted after
holding it in for all these
years Mr buus didn't live with Mrs
buckus
anymore he moved out because he too was
afraid of what would happen when she
couldn't hold it in any longer and he
didn't know how to help
they didn't have kids so Mrs buus lived
except for her Peekapoo
shamimi dog who loved
her uh with no ifans or
butts so this is sad dude this is she is
not happy no she's been dumped by this
guy and she still has gas and she still
doesn't know what's going to happen
people often stopped and stared when Mrs
buckus walked by because she was so huge
they didn't know about her problem she
kept it to herself and Mrs buckas like
to eat she also likeed to shop every
Tuesday she would walk to the grocery
and fill two carts with food then go
home to
eat on this particular Tuesday she was
failling her second cart and she had
just entered the fruit aisle suddenly an
irresistible urge came over her can you
guess what she wanted to
do what she needed to
do as she passed the
chanteloup Mrs buckus finally let
go dress is flying
up years and years of fart escaped with
a tremendous blast and the sound was
deafening it was the loudest and longest
fart ever recorded in history
the supermarket shook food fell to the
floor people yelled unsure of what had
happened the smell began to spread it
seemed like a mixture of rot BS and dead
scumps and old
poo customers tried to run toward the
door but no one made it everyone in the
store fainted before they could Escape
except Mrs buckus she stood as still as
a statue watching the commotion around
her she couldn't smell her own fart but
she saw what it did to everyone else she
was scared so she left her shopping cart
slowly moved around all the people who
had passed out and headed towards the
exit like you and I did when we burned
that apartment compx
that once back at her apartment Mrs
bukus felt wonderful her stomach felt
relieved too she couldn't believe that
she hadn't farted years ago
about the same time people began to
awaken in the grocery store one by one
they stood up and looked around the
store smelled awful but something else
had happened Mommy look at the
pineapple every fruit had changed color
the pears are blue oh my God lemons were
red orange is green apples were orange
and white polka dots cherries were were
yellow bananas were purple with the
yellow stripes plums were white
customers ran for the beautiful fruit
and began piling it into their shopping
carts in just a few minutes the shells
were bare long lines quickly formed at
the uh checkout counter the store
manager knew what had happened the big
lady's fart had changed the color of the
fruit he had to find her to make more of
it but nobody knew where she was words
spread around town about the fruit and
the next day hundreds of people rushed
to the store to buy it determined to
find Mrs buckus the manager posted the
sign on the window please come back fart
[Music]
woman a week later when she thought
nobody would remember her or the trouble
she caused Mrs buckus returned to the
grocery to to shop the sign on the door
stopped her in her tracks she knew it
was written about her they're really mad
at me she thought Mrs buckus went in
timidly and asked the manager and asked
for the manager when he when he appeared
she told him my name is Mrs buus I was
the one who farted last week I'm very
sorry the manager gave her a big
hug the best he could because she was a
he was a small man and she was a large
woman thank you for coming back he
gushed we're out of colored
fruit but Mrs buus was confused the
manager explained that her fart changed
the color of the fruit it tasted better
and every customer was begging for more
you'll never guess what happened next
the manager offered Mrs buckus a job
farting in the store at night that way
nobody would faint and she could color
the
fruit I can sell your fruit for three
times the price of regular fruit and I
can pay you very well the manager
promised I I bet this is well
received it is my god there you go Mrs
Buck has decided to take the job now she
goes to the store every night after
dinner far to the fruit aisle and when
she uh sees the bananas grapes
pineapples orang and plums melons and
lemons and limes change color her work
is done the customers are happy the
manager is happy and Mrs buckus is very
very
happy no
and it comes
with of Mrs
buckus uh
whoopy there it
is